chaos in modern times is an inside look
at their survivalist culture in the USA
as a participant observer
mr. Mitchell explores various
sociological and psychological theories
about their survivalist movement and
concludes that it's about more than an
outsider's need to get power but an
outlet for people often marginalized by
society to exercise their creativity and
gain success this program runs an hour
in ten minutes
good evening welcome to pals in
Hawthorne tonight in our ongoing series
of author events we are pleased to
welcome Richard Mitchell mr. Mitchell
joins us tonight to share in his latest
book dancing at Armageddon survivalism
and chaos and modern times there will be
time for questions and answers c-span is
with us tonight so please wait for mr.
Mitchell to recognize you and please
wait for the microphone before stating
your question ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming Richard
Mitchell I should say generous and
heartfelt thanks to the folks at pals
for making this evening possible you
know during my two-plus decades in
Oregon much of my time and certainly
much of the best time has been spent
wandering the aisles of pals various
stores through the enticing material
that surrounds us discovering the
wonderment and diversity of the human
condition
being here with all of you is a genuine
pleasure and honor and a stark contrast
some of the other things that I've done
as a sociologist for the past decade and
a half colleague alene Bauman and I have
been studying survivalists now to
understand survivalists start with the
notion that troubles might be coming to
America and that some people are looking
forward to them these enthusiasts for
trouble have been dubbed many things
citizens militias
protesters racial separatists
survivalists and others
I used survivalists in reference to the
whole for practical and theoretical
reasons because participants themselves
often do and because creative
problem-solving in the face of
cataclysmic troubles why is it the root
of this seemingly diverse events
anticipated troubles very environmental
catastrophe economic collapse civil
strife race war for an invasion even
thermonuclear war the survivalists I met
very - one built a $700,000 retreat in
the foothills of Montana complete with
bulletproof shutters and firing ports
alarm systems he had an entryway that
could be flooded with poison gas and
ears shattering sound waves it was
another fellow lived out of the back of
his 23-year old Volvo subsisting on
government food coupons and pigeons that
he snared in public parks with a deft
movement of a a collapsible trout
fishing net he could smear the pigeon
put the back of his coat and off he'd go
Mick and LeAnn who are within a few
miles of us at the present time live in
the basement of her parents home saving
money to enlarge their stash of some 14
firearms and 6,000 rounds of ammunition
and five goats and three sheep and a
peacock and five acres of retreat
property in California retired Army
colonel and self ordained Reverend Gail
sermonize de bout killing Jews and
overthrowing the government but he's
very careful not to jeopardize his own
generous military pension once wealthy
Canadian engineer Thomas wanted 500
volunteers to join him underground learn
to speak a new language read the
post-apocalyptic generation Mensa the
Society for persons with IQs
demonstrable above the norm has its own
a survivalist oriented subgroup of
computer programmers and engineers and
dentists and writers and
the professionals excuse me
sociology is a modern discipline in
modern times with sophisticated methods
and standard techniques ready at hand
for the study of many problems but not
all problems lend themselves to refined
method alone some sociology can only be
done down and dirty face to face in the
confrontations with the lives and works
and worlds of those that we would
understand at times researchers must be
more than methodical more than
technically competent we must enter our
subjects worlds on their terms be those
worlds congenial or repulsive clear or
confusing open or hostile I know this
now but it was a lesson I learned the
hard way at the beginning of our
survivals research because we knew so
little we convinced ourselves that we
knew much before we met a single
survivalist even before we left home we
had it all worked out what to do in the
fields of what to look for what
questions to ask how to act as it turned
out we were as clueless as we were
confident our first field trip went this
way
I've been trying to find survivalists
they're not afterall readily available
for months and I came across the address
of live free Inc an Illinois based
organization that claimed to have a
branch in the Pacific Northwest
I wrote we exchanged letters and phone
calls and then there's no to write
handwritten note and it read I'll share
it with you
dear survivalist and Patriots October
one and two the American pistol and
rifle association in coordination with
live free ink will be holding a defense
operation seminar in the barkerville
National Forest bring firearms if you
don't have anything more than a 20 to
bring it this is a school it's important
to come the instructors are good classes
will cover map and compass problems code
patrolling ambush encounter ambush recon
scout and night perimeter ops and there
was an equipment list equipment
od green clothing or camis tan teen
small pack rifle or shotgun and there
was a list of rules a all participants
will respect the flag in the US
Constitution B there will be no profane
language C there will be no illegal
weapons and so forth six more rules
followed then there was a hand-drawn map
and sketches of two fire-breathing rifle
barrels and one was labeled rat-tat and
the other one was labeled live free and
the letter was signed Jim Watkins
well Alena and I talked about beasts the
rules seemed reasonable we called for
final permission and directions and with
trepidation and new camouflage clothing
in a borrowed shotgun we wit it took 13
hours of driving across two states to
reach the dirt road junction designated
as our rendezvous Saturday 7:45 a.m.
worn and sleepless from our long drive
and active nerves we did as we have been
told pulled to the roadside in plain
view
shut off the engine remain in the
vehicle someone will come for you
Jim had promised who or how he had not
told us we watched the mirrors in the
road ahead and bolstered our courage by
ridiculing ours yet unmet subjects
rumors exaggerated survivalism we were
sure survivalists were probably nothing
to worry about nothing really strange
we made nervous fun of the countryside
nearby yesterday land we called it a
sort of a forgotten Disney attraction in
appearance the area through which we had
driven since dawn did seem a piece out
of America that was out of time if not
place tiny towns were connected by dirt
roads pine and fir forests and Bluffs
and Hills were separated by clear
streams road signs gate posts and the
few people we saw suggested a sparse
population of cattle ranchers and ever
hopeful miners and out-of-work loggers
and ostracized Indians even the map
names with the old-world theme
the Old West theme Bear Mountain Cougar
Mountain quartz mountain iron mountain
lay in the cardinal directions around us
the road head went down refrigerator
Canyon along Rabbit Creek and around
Gold Hill just south of the all-american
town of Liberty at the general store in
the gas station a few miles back we got
orange juice and directions from a
proprietor who it seemed to us wore his
holstered revolver as casually as his
cowboy boots that gesture ease his good
good fight at Rosie's bar last night he
confided nodding to the two disheveled
coffee drinkers on the front porch at
8:15 amid dust and loose engine noises a
car pulled in behind us I met my first
survivalist like the displaced Gentry of
industrializing England Jim Watkins was
a man of many titles but few possessions
in his correspondence he called himself
the [ __ ] illusi mountain national
survival association group ice field
operations director or sergeant major
Jim Watkins member survival base board
of directors or regional director of
live free Inc today he was just Jim
Jim's 18-year old Chevrolet leaked
fluids and fumes as we watched and was
corrugated on three corners that's my
Mexican APC he joked APC is military
shorthand for armored personnel carrier
Jim's back seat was filled with plastic
buckets and tools and blankets camping
gear and what he called his battle rifle
which was a World War one bolt-action
British Enfield Jim was in his early 30s
trim about 510 he wore a uniform of
assorted Vietnam era surplus garments
after some mutual identity checking he
told us the exercise was about to begin
a short distance away you'll need Henry
there he told us he runs the live free
group in your area Henry and live free
turned out to be real enough but for
much of the weekend
we weren't quite sure about Jim he ended
back towards his car and then to his
surprise he turned he stopped he looked
towards us he came to a military
attention he started to salute the
gesture was interrupted when the only
when his hand got about shoulder high
hopped in his car follow me
he instructed out the open passenger
window as we drove by Johnson down the
hill we followed in in a few minutes
found ourselves in the middle of a
isolated clearing in a heavily timbered
forest we were surrounded by
survivalists none of them were like Jim
the clearing was ringed with primer
spotted domestic pickups and 4-door
sedans with black wall recaps and
six-digit mileage men with guns large
and small caliber assault rifles
sidearms grenade launchers submachine
guns stood about chatting and smoking
and loading ammunition magazines and
examining each other's weapons they were
well used military camouflage over
modest denim and polyester ready wear
their build caps and the buckles of
their necessarily ample belts proclaimed
allegiance to brands of trucks and farm
machinery two men performed these
survivalists while at sharing a truck
side mirror as they painted their faces
and ears and neck with dappled green and
brown makeup these Sioux and others
looked Marshall the man squatted before
us across the smoldering campfire looked
primeval this apparition was wearing a
ghillie suit the ultimate in portable
concealment a handmade hood and cloak of
dark fishnet through which uneven
earth-tone rags had been woven and tied
twigs and leaves were added for accent
if you could imagine a Sesame Street Big
Bird Pelt darkened tattered and soil as
we watched he poured half
water from his canteen into a pile of
ash at the fire pits edge then with both
hands he began kneading this slurry into
a loose paste small amounts of dirt and
spittle were added the paste stiffened
he looked up from his work and gave us a
steady glance then to our amazement he
lured his face into these handfuls of
mud and began smearing the mixture
carefully into the creases and hollows
over all the exposed skin on his head
for several moments only the rustling
ghillie suit was visible then he again
looked up only the eyes reminded me of
humanity the rest was transformed into a
kind of Filth covered primitive man
thing I stared at it it's their back the
thing fastidiously wiped its hands on a
patch of grass rose from its haunches
stepped around the fire and stood square
in front of me and extended one hand and
almost to my surprise spoke hello it
said I'm Henry now we tried to prepare
for this moment we followed directions
we were on time we brought what we could
have the required gear we wanted to be
unobtrusive scientists to blend in
Henry's directs there now join the
others we had received since our arrival
we had not been overlooked
into this circle of camouflaged men
riding battered Detroit iron and armed
to the teeth
we had come nearly empty handed driving
a late-model diesel-powered Puzo station
wagon disguised for the occasion and
freshly pressed discounts door duck
hunting outfits over preppy l.l.bean
pants Patagonia jackets and Nike
trainers in a short while ambush
maneuvers and gunplay began over the
next two days we learned how to whisper
and creep how to handle weapons how to
shoot at people and some
time's something else our attempts at
disguise were paradox kind of successful
failures instead of hiding us they made
us the center of positive attention
after all who else but naive enthusiasts
would wear such ludicrous costumes we
were accepted treated with general
respect even praised we never went
unnoticed bus was our first day in the
field let me say some things about the
other end of the research many years
looking back a brief if you will
synopsis that the argument that spite
might be made regarding the why of
survivalism modern social life modernity
gives us more things more things to own
and consume more facts to analyze more
ways to communicate but it also leaves
us less less to do that really matters
morally and practically in society at
large less capacity to influence the
course of culture less attached to place
and community we may own much but what
we accomplish as individuals sometimes
diminishes towards choice between
meaningless alternatives shopping mall
fashions top 40 music Big Mac and IHOP
cuisine in the salon one of the things
that sociologists have observed over the
years in the paper and pencil tests that
they have applied to us North American
populations industrialized populations
around the world studying the phenomenon
alienation is that there is a particular
segment of the population that seems to
be insulated that seems to be
independent that seems to be resistant
to this problem
people who ranked lowest on the index of
alienation or those who install
machinery and repair it when it begins
to fail repairers then enjoy work more
they derive more
their efforts they set their own work
pace they command a wide range of skills
they exercise considerable amount of
crap it's often dirty work difficult and
sometimes dangerous
but it's also challenging it's full of
variety now there's an important point
here breakdown then may be the surest
antidote for feelings of alienation in
modern workplace and not all challenge
producing breakdown need be mechanical
national boundaries breakdown ethnic
identities breakdown at least in
imagination political and economic
structures are at risk knowledge systems
other elements of culture may weaken and
need refurbishment or deteriorate and
require rebuilding crises chaos even
Doomsday's have their latent allure
along with uncertainty and danger comes
opportunities for creative engagement in
meaningful concrete work that matters
honest tests of character with the
faithful forces of some imaginary New
Age survivalism is a celebration of
these changes largely an imaginative
narrative rehearsal survivalism away is
a way of revitalizing daily life of
introducing meaningful challenge
adventure compelling significance
urgency to everyday affairs it's less
reactive than proactive less a retreat
from social life than a novel
exploration of its possibilities
it's an encompassing non-trivial game of
make-believe survivalist creates stories
of pending troubles that maximize their
own opportunities to improvise and
invent to use what skills and resources
they have to secure and protect and
renew family and community and nation
survivalism allows ordinary people to
imagine themselves being extraordinarily
useful
what you have is what you need
you're a survivalist troubles come only
when the survival is already and only in
the forms for which they've prepared
those who hoard valuables and envision
fiscal they are the ones who envision
fiscal instability the ones with guns
and other tools tell tales of urgent
defense or repair those with shelters
attend to the possibilities in nuclear
fallout
life is challenging neither overwhelming
nor dull survivalists are messengers
longing to be troubadours they're
individuals longing to stand center
stage amid grand events and sing of epic
deeds survivalism like art promises what
rational life does not grand eloquent
symbolic means of making a difference
personally and morally in modern times
let me ask if you folks have any
questions at this point before I
continue on Kurt and Donna
see
so what I hear you saying is that this
is really a creative response to
feelings and anime products no yes
indeed Oh ennui perhaps a better turn
not a sense of powerlessness or
purposelessness not a sense of
inadequacy but a sense of not enough
things to do that matter and maybe your
you'll get to it but I take a major
theme that you haven't touched on is the
notion that government is the enemy and
to be prepared for Nevada the there are
varieties of ways of slicing the pie
often the slicing is done by the media
and we are given various impressions
about what it is to be a survivalist and
these are trimmed and brought to us the
anti-government theme is a popular one
let me see if I can put the
anti-government theme in context for for
you first there's a very long answer to
that maybe we'll get to it in a couple
of pieces government is one of many
things that are discussed trouble is has
its allure it might be government
trouble it might be extra national
trouble it might be troubles within the
gene pool it might be troubles with the
economy there's a a generous tolerance
for alternative discourses with regard
to trouble dramatic tolerance for that
let's put the story of government
troubles in a survivalist context there
is an expo a gathering of thousands of
survivalists in Seattle a couple of
years ago in a large convention center
there are booths that are selling
various survivalist oriented goods dried
foods accessories for firearms
shelter construction materials materials
about various isms and ologies that are
problematic all of this is going on in
this large assembly hall I am there for
three days I am at this time in one
booth the proprietors of which are two
men Duane and Frankie and they have
before them Oh small knives that they
sell and they have pepper spray and they
have accessories for firearms and they
have naturopathic cures for cancer and
the whole range of Ottomans and they are
survivalists now tall athletic-looking
Duane is sort of an Aryan info model
he's trim and as the white doctor is
below and this sort of blonde chest hair
curling out of his unbuttoned collar of
his mesomorphic Lee bulging polo shirt
his partner is is a kind of Frankie is
the sort of such a putz of the pair he's
a half a foot shorter he's balding he's
not recently washed he's more shaped
like a stop sign than a yield sign and
they're talking survivalist politics
we've been at this for half an hour or
so now what survivalist politics it's
not the new world order taking over but
it's things that really matter to
survivalist like how do you negotiate a
high-traffic place for your table when
you go to the Expos and where do you get
merchandise from room with plenty of
markup and complaints about long drives
and lousy motels and uncomfortable vans
now there's a reporter and a cameraman
from the local TV station who are
working their way down the aisle any
spot Dwayne and Frankie and they stop at
his place and it is time for survivalism
in the public realm to be created the
reporter opens with the usual sort of
question what are you all you
survivalists getting ready for what are
you afraid of
now the cameraman points to Dwayne the
reporter goes over and pushes the
cameras it's not Frankie he's good and
disreputable looking Frankie senses
opportunity it's his turn to play and
please the crowd its standard fare and
he pulls himself out from behind the
boxes and he puts on this early looking
face and he starts with the usual
material you people in the media and the
standard themes government is out of
control
what the founding fathers intended
foreign influence is ruining America
what the people's rights are with regard
to protecting themselves what doctors
won't tell you
and so the crowd heads not the reporter
axle arm the cameraman gets a close-up
of Frankie news is created a good time
is had by all
up to seven or eight minutes the TV crew
moves on crowd moves in doing the
Frankie do a brief brisk business about
20 minutes later things are back to
normal
Frankie and I take a break I join him
for coffee I asked him about the episode
with the TV crew his speech and his
opinions tell me what you think about
government and he brightens he owns
lodges he's sexist cut uppity beams
Frankie thinks very well of his
performance that was fun I had him going
it was great I got in all my lines did
you see that reporter sweat sure of
business too I like to get the crowd
with me know there was a rhetoric an
anti-government rhetoric it was fairly
common but it was without place or
purpose outside of the dramaturgy
outside of that moment that was created
in conflict and in public conflict
indeed when we find survivalists
together
in large gatherings as I'd suggested
there's a great tolerance for different
narratives let's see if there's any
other questions we'll come back to that
diversity of narratives I once read a
book called behold a pale horse and it
was sort of about more about UFOs and
abductions and things like that but I
wondered if there was if you found any
connection between any of the other
fringe groups like survivalists and UFOs
or no people that have different or
varying beliefs like these these other
sociological groups did you find them
blending or crossing over or if you
could speak to that
good question absolutely um one
distinctive characteristic of
survivalists across the board is they
their troubles are concrete they are not
spiritual they are not transcending our
sort of concrete obdurate world in which
we can encounter with normal sensations
and access to conventional perceptional
devices so the UFOs the religious
phenomena that we sometimes find on the
borders are descriptions of second
comings or other kinds of spiritual
emanations are outside the boundaries
now if indeed rumors of UFOs lead to
real riots the survivalists might be
concerned but they would credential the
notion of extraterrestrials for example
only a very small amount this they would
not attend to what they're concerned
with is things that are concrete
palpable observable and accessible for
an eerie narration reinterpretation now
obviously there are interpretations
sometimes are quite odd quite exotic
quite diverse or disparate from perhaps
the the truth testing that you and I
might use but they want to have a
concrete base do they have some
tolerance for other points of view yes
very much so
and
I'll tell that story briefly there's a
horrible place one of the one of the one
of the darkened and most disturbing
moments of this research took place in
the central California foothills in a
training camp run by a reverend William
Potter Gale and in three days at 18
hours of sermons he spluttered hatred of
Jews and practical means of killing them
of overthrowing government ridding the
nation of foreign influence he taught us
how to organize assassinations to form
our own bug groups that's bellied up in
the grass he taught us how to slash
abdomens and gouge out eyes and locked
heads off with piano wire it was a vile
hate-filled time all of these words were
incandescent in their horror over and
over again we heard from the podium the
most disturbing of rhetoric but then I
had to ask myself what did people do in
that context were they led to mayhem
were they led to forming their own bug
groups who were they led to subsequent
crime quite different
after the sermons there was time for
lunch there were frequent breaks I'll
give you an example of one break we sat
outdoors in groups of seven or eight
crowded around picnic tables fixing
lunch from kitchen supplies in basic
colors white bread and mayonnaise yellow
mustard orange cheese green relish red
Bologna and ketchup and kool-aid
participants took turns showcasing their
own variants of survivalism topics
shifted in wide compass around the table
and each narrator was granted attention
by the others polite questions inquiry
but never contradicted as I recall the
circle began something like this there
was a discourse on Christ's true ethnic
origins something to do with the fact
that he wasn't a Jew and didn't speak
Hebrew people heads not and people asked
mild questions the next person in line
how to discourse on the secrets of
buying discount truck tires yes this too
was an important topic cheek by jowl
with the ethnic origins of Christ the
secret there by the ways you must buy
tires that are compounded for use on
roads in the East that's better rubber
than the Western next was a narration on
prohibitions against eating wild game
meat and anything with paws and the
evidence that was offered in this regard
was sort of a tripartite argument
derived from FDA nutrition pamphlets and
the Koran and the Bible well happily
mixed together again
the heads nod occasionally people take a
note there's no contradiction there's no
disagreement there is no conflict
between these perspectives because
what's going on here
is the purpose of this gathering is not
to be revolutionaries but to find a
forum to find an opportunity to
craft a bit of culture however odd and
exotic and perhaps even distorted it by
again seen from our perspective and to
find a tolerant audience to tell the
story it's not the correspondence
between the empirical and the narration
that is critical but it's the coherence
of the story itself how well told is it
how much does it make us think about
things we might have overlooked or
possibilities yet to be imagined
continued around the circle that was
Tesla's secret Deathrays now being
deployed by the Russians
these were revealed there were two
people who spoke about contemporary
health matters in ways which they can be
improved by polarizing the
electromagnetic forces of surfaces or
cooking surfaces and our drinking water
and managing our intake variously of
oxygen and ozone and air and fluids and
various kinds of pond scum elixirs all
of this went on round the circle it all
that went on for purposes of the
narration there is a dark side to this
these were the adults these were the
mature individuals who took from this
opportunity who took from this this
gathering the opportunity to tell their
own stories maybe later we'll get to the
darkest part of that perhaps the best
characters is Zilla the end of the table
there's a little gal she's 70 years old
she's one inch shorter than five feet
tall she's ten pounds shorter than a
hundred weight she is wearing a
survivalist costume she has crafted of
her own sort as if you can imagine sort
of a Joseph's coat of mottled greens and
browns
it's a lined in gray flannel as
synthetic bone buttons pockets big
enough for a Bible on one side this big
packet of flyers on the other
you know sort of add a elastic waistband
pants and natty beret of the same
material little child size hiking boots
finish the ensemble imagine little green
riding hood with an arthritic left hip
and a sheaf of flyers that zip right as
it was a survivalist her plan is for
political reform they haven't heard
about that yet back to government right
her plan is radically Democratic
unlikely and in the usual survivalist
fashion this is expounded at leaf she
has of course the typical survivalist
handout which is utopian and long-winded
full of details about specific ales of
government the evils of various isms and
if you imagine a detective so technical
solutions all this is sort of been tiny
Zilla size prints nine pages both sides
now zilla's vision goes something like
this
she is streamlined democracy to its most
intimate forms the New England town
meeting or the Swiss canton assembly
writ large she calls this freedoms last
straw what freedoms last straw entails
is a constitutional amendment that will
allow easily initiated national
referendum printed ballots and local
newspapers free public phones and secret
voting codes and this will allow direct
voting by all citizens now given these
mechanisms all we need is an enlightened
four enlightened self-governance is of
course an unbiased news coverage which
is quite confident will be forthcoming
and voters can from that source learn
about the facts and learn about all
sides you guys making it okay
all right it's an organ day folks we
love it an organ day at Powell's is not
to be denied it's a good experience so
public opinion will rule supreme
politicians will be unnecessary so
there's a diversity of points of view
I'll humble up on this thing a little
bit make some noise seeing it closer
here how's that all right does endorse
it your points of view they're all
tolerated not because any one of them is
constitutes a final truth but it is in
the tally that the reward is found for
survivalists it's not a competition for
whose truth will ring remain I most
successful or most accepted widely
accepted in the long run this is a
common misconception amongst the media
is that they're arguing for an
alternative reality no they're arguing
for the right behind the podium the
chance to tell tales anybody else yes
sir with the the studies that you're
making which are I can imagine quite a
few different directions that can build
to a conclusion I wonder if you
adventure a prophetic statement for us
this evening yes I would I was gonna say
that too later I I think this is correct
a question of what the future holds it's
a good question it's an important
question it's one that I think we should
reflect upon long it's been easy enough
to dismiss survivalism as some odd Karen
they are odd indeed it often exotic and
sometimes strange and it sometimes
prescient thoughtful well-read
if we can dismiss survivalism as a
striving for a place in the manufacture
of culture if we can say that all that
matters to be happy and successful to be
integrated in Western industrial society
is to own things and to be able to
consume and we don't need to pay that
you to survive us but I do and think I
think for many of us that is
unsatisfactory we have modern work that
encourages obscurity be messengers they
tell us not those troubadours fall of
formulas apply theories report facts
leave things as they are ladle out the
textbook content bolt on the replacement
parts assembled the units manufactured
elsewhere dispense someone else's pills
enforce rules not of our own making on
people not of our own choosing
not everyone satisfied with this what
the future holds
I do not know perhaps peace perhaps
plenty but of this I am certain to
endure today's societies must offer more
than security and comfort they must
answer the question who shall create
culture in ways as generous and
inclusive as justice and equity are now
sought ways must be found for people of
varied means an imagination to craft
culture as well as consume it for to be
sure ways will be found licit and
welcomed or otherwise and some may be
inconsequential and some may be a boon
but some may bring genius and depravity
together
my view of the future other questions
there did did you observe any hybrids of
people who have a kind of environmental
sensitivity who want to live off of the
electricity grid and grow their own food
and yet had some things in common with
this survival culture I want to say no
because the predominant interest the
ready-made accoutrements these simple
tools that can be used for leverage were
so dominant in much of the discourse if
we could imagine for a moment the
leverage that is possible if there is an
economic collapse some environmental
catastrophe and we happen to be the
individuals who have a few simple tools
a chainsaw a pickup truck perhaps an
assault weapon although put them in
context some food storage other
implements the leverage is considerable
the narrative leverage is considerable
you can tell a neat rounded tale to tell
the story of independence from the grid
of independence upon tools is probably
something that many survivalists feel a
resonance towards but it wasn't as easy
a story to tell and I heard few but not
I wouldn't say none there were one or
two that were part of that but the
notion of a few simple tools that what
one can do with these these objects I
mean there's a there's a fellow
relatively nearby here who at least a
couple of years ago had amassed an
entire garage double car garage
he was a an employee of government a
civil engineer he amassed an entire
double car garage filled with toilet
paper and paper towels and soap and
detergent now his professional concerns
were with regard to public health
in order to craft the narrative of
course his notion of breakdown had to do
with the destruction of the public sewer
systems public health so he needed those
tokens if you will those implements are
the soap powder and the paper the point
two as his indices of his own
preparation could he do without them
probably yes
did he know anyone else yes an idea of
the demographic of the people that you
encountered sure as far as men versus
women and families versus singles right
if I can do this off the top of my head
a very non surprising population and
derive not from all the people with whom
I spoke but a sample of some 248
individuals who volunteered volunteered
on a biographical material this is not
Survey Research but indeed material er I
was able to glean from personal
correspondence and other sources out of
that 248 90% of them were male almost
all of them were white not all but
almost all of them are white they were
38 years of age on the average they had
two years of university education on the
average to play about half of the Mormon
I'm sorry excuse me
three-quarters of them were married
about two point two children one in five
had military service and almost all of
those in non-combat capacities you stop
and think about it that for a moment if
you changed the education level in
describing a State College liberal arts
faculty
this is not an unusual population at are
there urban dwellers or sub urban
dwellers not rural dwellers as the the
media would often lead us to believe
quite conventional in many respects now
some things they do that are not
conventional they don't watch television
when I say they don't watch television
they might watch two or three hours of
television as opposed to the roughly
eight hours a day in which television is
on in the typical American home what
they watch is news almost all will
express a keen disregard or distrust of
of television and or a disrespect for
its content
they are least of all interest in sports
and other kinds of sitcoms soap operas
and other kinds of passive fantasy
entertainments they're in the business
of creating their own narratives they do
have some respect for the news media but
then with a considerable amount of
criticism that is directed at as well
the language is temperate universally
temperate they drink little or not at
all
they are chivalrous in their own way
their notion of appropriate gender roles
is old-fashioned and decorous we would
say perhaps deeply sexist in some
respects so the behavior is somewhat
different they are not good old boys
drinking beer in the backyard at all
what else yes yes sir
what you just described is greatly at
odds with the media stereotype and
presentation that's given to us on a
quite regular basis I'm sure you're
aware that of the stereotype why do you
suspect that there is this attempt
perhaps it's a wider cultural prejudice
or just through the media why is that
there this negativity attached well I'm
not sure it's that we need to look to
ideology or a sense of willfulness on
the part of anybody but after all lots
of people are competing for control of
trouble narratives what do our
newspapers strive upon what does our
television programming primarily thrive
upon what do we expect in the paper
trouble and indeed we get it problems of
interpersonal conflict resulting in
crime and violence problems of
international conflicts and this is what
we expect we don't expect benign and you
know comforting poetic tales about the
human condition academics are in the
business of telling trouble tales as
well whether they be concerns about
environmental pending crises or social
conflicts so I don't find it unusual at
all that the media would emphasize and
sometimes caricature and even at times
fabricate and you'll see in in the book
a number of instances where the very
image of the survivalists itself was it
was a pure fabrication on the part of
the meat I don't I'm not surprised that
they would do this after all the
survivalists are in the business of
telling trouble tales as are many others
in that instance they're quite
conventional they're part of the
American drama and they may tweak and
emphasize and dramatize and poured out
the evils of those isms and our ologies
with greater vigor than they feel as do
other media I'm not sure it's some
malignant willfulness on their part it's
the way we do business
perhaps the academics are the most
pronounced in that regard particularly
within the realms of post-modernism
where we're arguing that the entire
human condition is now impossible
social this course is impossible the
possibility of knowing the other is no
longer there poor survivalists have to
compete with an awful lot of
professional trouble mongers yes sir
the subject of of the future yes and the
the raising of the conscious level of
humanity that that area right there
where although the media may say that we
see this portrayal of fight and flight
mentality of a survivalism survivalists
but but the the cross-section your your
seeing is more of an intelligent type of
people the type of people that are very
capable of raising the conscious level
of humanity and I'm wondering if you're
seeing a groundswell of that and what's
being what they're doing about it or is
there any leadership going on there no
there isn't any leadership that again is
a very good point precisely there's no
leadership because to have leadership we
would have to have some commonality in
the narrative some commonality in the
discourse and the point that was raised
before is that we have this tolerance
for an enormous diversity this path row
of tales
and if you want to come up with another
tale a new kind of trouble the podium is
yours you're welcome
fabricate a new one but organizing a
movement coalescing persons to get them
to march in some direction to get them
to effect some change what pretty
suppose that they're all going to agree
on things that need to be changed and
that I think we would find highly
problematic perhaps access to for oh
would be the first the first change that
people would hope for denominator as far
as a culture being developed that is
agreeable common element in culture only
the dissatisfaction with consumer
society and that was quite consistent
across the survival aspect
what you do to be a crafter of culture
is your own independent volitional act
that's up to you and and one is
encouraged given the opportunity to do
so within within the survivalist milieu
the the common dissatisfaction would be
with consumerism I'm not sure that that
is by the way a dissatisfaction that is
shared only by survivalists yes sir it
seems that you you cast these people as
as common suburban folk who are sort of
having a good time going to conventions
traveling around perhaps living in
communes oftentimes in the media we've
seen these people some of the more
dangerous or extremes like I think that
what happened at Waco with David Koresh
they might have been seen miss
survivalist or even if I'm not mistaken
Timothy McVeigh may have been seen as
involved with survivalists in that
regard those types of people do you see
those people as susceptible to
manipulation by foreign radicals that
would that would seek to harm the United
States no not at all a good question
though at first the examples the
extremist examples again back this
gentleman's question are the best ways
of selling newspapers the tremendous
efforts were made to bring Timothy
McVeigh into the the arena of
survivalism there was no credible link
he didn't belong he didn't participate
he didn't craft his own narrative he was
unto himself largely unto himself an
independent actor but he made good press
and if we need as outsiders to the
survivalist phenomena to coalesce these
activities into groups and organizations
and movements and collective phenomena
and that's what happened with Timothy
McVeigh he was given the label of
survivalists indeed several others have
throughout history but the the ones that
were marked these distinctive these most
virulent and and violent of characters
are not the ones who belong to the very
kinds of
communities of discourse that I'm
talking about they don't go to the
meetings they don't share the pamphlets
they don't have the other four in which
to participate are they accessible to
foreign radicals and influence from the
outside I would say they'd be quite
resistant to that indeed they've
rejected virtually every source of
information that accessible to them in
our own culture and stepped aside and
said they'll craft their own their own
independent notion we might also mention
I'll just throw this out and see if it
comes up here in a moment the fact that
there are ambiguities they're not all
survivalists are totally committed to
their scenarios by any means they tell
the story they don't live the life
sometimes they tell part of the story
and are reticent to finish sometimes
they participate in training or
activities and are reluctant to continue
they too don't like the sound of their
own words the consequences even in
imagination of their own action and they
self censor oh sorry I just I can see
the adults like like pulling into that I
think you had a comment earlier too
about the children and in regards to
what happened at Columbine I wonder if
you see that that some of the younger
people maybe more at risk too
maybe even more so than from video game
violence or something of that nature
this is the hardest part of the tale to
tell the adults by and large not
Columbine here but the adults by and
large were able to separate at least in
my observation these were not
universally individuals with whom I
would have a positive relationship whose
perspectives I respected but they were
able to strike a balance between tale
telling and action somewhere in Midland
let me if I might tell two stories
one of the ambivalence of survivalism
and then two of the wrenching problems
that occur when there is no longer or
has yet to be developed the capacity to
distinguish between these two it was the
hardest experience for me in all of my
years in the field these now nearly two
decades the hardest experience of all
was to encounter those who could not
strike that balance and to have to live
with the fact that that was part of the
world in which I found myself Uncle
Terry wins reverend gales encampments
amidst the hour upon hour day upon day
of anti-semitic rhetoric and training
Uncle Terry character worth remembering
Uncle Terry hunted coyotes for a living
he worked wholesale for the Bureau of
Land Management and occasionally retail
for a rancher he was a big man six foot
six inches tall weighed 240 pounds he
smelled of automobile oil
he carried a Bible with all these
bristling notes across the top that
marked memorable sections I sat next to
him in church three days running his
permanent press brown polyester slacks
were to shorten the legs he wore clean
white socks inside work boots scuffed
down on the inside
who'sa pronator he could use orthotics
Uncle Terry was my partner for garroted
practice now our grits were obviously
not wires with handles on them else I
would not be telling this tale we use
rolled bath towels 40 of us assembled
out on the lawn the training ground some
women about 10%
our victim partners were expected to to
stand passively facing away as we crept
forward and dropped the towel noose into
place with the proper motions I missed
the towel hooked under uncle Terry's
nose instead of a grot victim there was
a series of these sort of muffled
mumbles Terri Gail the supervisor of the
camp stopped the practice and he drew
others attention to our errors then he
spoke to Uncle Terry says now you do it
he ordered Uncle Terry Uncle Terry
looked nervous under this close scrutiny
he spat neatly into the Dustin took up
his position I did as well I faced away
into the Sun footsteps suddenly I was I
was off my feet bent backwards over
uncle Terry's broad shoulders semi
throttled with this towel and I wriggled
held high Gayle walked around us as if
we were mannequins slowly reviewing the
proper forms and elements of grotty
finally he released Uncle Terry from his
obligation you put him down now no I was
a bit blue and bruised but breathing and
I sat on the ground Uncle Terry came
over and hunched over me and he was
Fanning with a towel and so the
afternoon went that evening the day's
work done but not the nights we filed
back indoors for rest and spaghetti and
subdued sort of unfocused conversation
we were sitting in chairs scattered
about the kitchen in the rear of the
church sanctuary which was a large
mobile home extended trout trailer
second helpings were put out leisurely
then uncle Terry's time was up Uncle
Terry shuffled in our direction stuffing
his mouth with a roll as he came
excusing his delayed speech
Uncle Terry bearish shy this shovel had
something uncomfortable to say but the
words weren't quite ready yet he
prepared in darkness kind of squinting
his eyes nearly closed to eating slowly
with the last swallow of roll his
defense is gone he opened his eyes and
he blurted sorry and then came this long
string of apologies I'm sorry I didn't
mean to I'm sorry are you all right you
okay really are you Uncle Terry didn't
like this karate practice he did said he
didn't like hurting people hurting
people was bad he said hurting animals
was bad you should never leave an animal
to suffer never began apologizing again
when I finally convinced him that he'd
done me no permanent harm he beamed and
he shook my hands solemnly and he
offered what for Uncle Terry were really
meaningful amends Uncle Terry was a big
man with a big appetite the part of
dinner that he'd been looking forward to
all afternoon was dessert the chocolate
cake he had two pieces and he gave them
both to me placing each one carefully on
my plate with his large bare hand one at
a time like this he seldom got cake at
home he explained because I got a bunch
of kids and being a trapper we just get
by how many kids I asked him as it
turned out one for each year of his
formal education after dinner there were
Vespers and then ambush practice and
maneuvers in the woods and then we were
in bed by 10:00 sorry
and then the hardest part of the weekend
perhaps the hardest part of all the
research Sunday morning the camp was up
early as we packed preparing to depart
leaned and I heard sounds outside the
small travel trailer that we had been
allotted as our space to stay during our
time of camp we heard sounds outside our
trailer terrible sounds the sounds of
children playing one child about five
years old darted among the dormitory
trailers chased by two others perhaps
two or three years older the pursuers
threw curses and stones as they ran one
stone struck our trailer another hit the
youngest child he took refuge below our
window sobbing quietly don't hurt me he
pleaded upon being discovered
laughing the older boys pushed him into
the ground that forces face into the
dirt the biggest sat on him twisting his
arm up behind his back
I'm here to break your fingers he
taunted then I'll break your legs
put him in pain put him in agony
encouraged his partner I want to kill
him said the biggest yeah the other
agreed slit his throat he's a Jew he's a
Jew the breakfast bell rang it was time
for church for special service to
rejoice and give thanks it was Easter
morning
when we left Gail's ranch Sunday
afternoon I drove slowly half a dozen
miles my mind in jitterbug confusion had
all this been real did we hear correctly
did we see it seemed not possible not
believable could there be with us on the
same planet in the same time and place
such an affliction of spirit such
cruelty and loathsome corrosion of what
I believed it was to be human no of
course not
in a few more miles as Freud promised I
begin to build walls fantasies it was
all absurd I was sure a colossal joke
sort of embarrassing bit of social
flatulence I began to chuckle and then
laugh on down the road and and what a
joke it was funny very funny and allene
sat beside me a stone silent my mirth
increased it became shrill how hilarious
it had all been those sermons those
exercises that was a real good one shut
up Pauline said simply I continued to
laugh shut up she insisted I pulled the
car to the roadside turned off the
engine and still smiling
turned towards her and when she saw the
sardonic rictus on my face she was
gentle shut up she soothed quietly
please I looked over my hunched right
shoulder and my torso was still facing
straight forward arms held stiffly ten
in two o'clock tightly gripping the
steering wheel as that was I was as if I
was hurtling down the twisty mountain
road at high speed life and death in my
grip don't let go the corners of my
mouth strained to reach my ears pulling
pulling cracking my lips
straining all the muscles of my face
into a kind of rigid twitch
grin mask and there was pain from this
and I welcomed it my front teeth began
to dry I wanted to rip my face in half
and throw away the eyes and ears that
had seen and heard this weekend the
mouth that had agreed and asked and then
I wept bitterly uncontrollably aleem
drove twenty more minutes to a small
town and found a phone I was 42 years
old and a male but no man not for this I
regressed became childish I called for
help to one who was stronger than I one
who had been face to face with
homelessness and concentration camps and
McCarthyism and kept his humanity intact
please dad I asked what does this mean
how can we hate each other so much for
so little for a sliver of faith or a
shade of skin or our way of making words
all right thank you folks
Richard Mitchell is a professor of
sociology at Oregon State University
he's author of dancing at Armageddon
survivalism and chaos in modern times
it's published by University of Chicago
Press visit press news